[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today I'm going to
show you how to get
started using Brocade vADC
products in Google Cloud
Launcher.
In Cloud Launcher, search
using the keyword Brocade.
Multiple offerings of either
the vTM, WAF, or the bundle
are shown.
Click on a standard vTM
and vWAF as an example,
and click on the Launch on
Google Cloud Platform button.
Select an existing project,
or Create New Project.
Click on Continue.
Leave the Name, Zone, Computer
Resources, and Firewall Rules
as defaults, or
change them as needed.
Click on Create to
create the instance.
Once the instance is created,
click on the instance name
on the VM Instances page.
Scroll all the way down, and
click on Serial Console Output.
Again, scroll down to see
the generated password.
In the VM Instances
page, click on Admin
Address to configure the vTM,
and use the generated password.
To get started with Brocade
vADC on Cloud Launcher, click
on the link in the comments.
Thanks for watching.